[Musik]
hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal und zwar zu einer nicht lachen
stellen weiter nicht lachen challenge
geht es darum dass man ja halt nicht
lacht und immer wenn ich lache muss ich
einen irgendwas zu trinken
ich habe mir extra solche irgendwas mit
zitronen drin gekauft sie sind richtig
sauer und ich würze angefangen direkt an
ok-chef attacken hühnerfüße diesmal wird
und die acht gefährlichsten für dich und
alle bevor ich gleich den ersten in
warschau trinken will ich sagen hören
uns zumindest noch mal den witz an
treffen sich zwei jäger eine tot
[Gelächter]
reichlich mein gott ich weiß ich aber
dass auf der kamera kennt weil der
autofokus eben nur um geschützt ist
einfach so kleine stückchen halten
jedoch passieren so dranhängt das sind
einfach das sind das sind irgendwas
stückchen auf euch
und wenn du jetzt wie katzenfleisch das
ist nicht wahr ich war weder die scheiße
da drum herum schwimmen
das jahr
[Musik]
der erste war schlimmer baustopp hier
ich hab nicht gedacht
ich habe nur eine frage am sonntag wird
gesagt wir bauen den flieger aus papier
aber das ist augenscheinlich kein papier
dann ist ein blatt aber er hat der wille
zählt dieses man abschließt rief ich
werde euch verlassen nicht guten tag
alle sind verblassen weg auf so grausame
welt es gibt keinen hält jeder tag ist
leicht wellig da kriege ich auch ganz
genau jetzt netzwerk im vorfeld muss
ich finde es klasse wie viel mühe sich
leute dann mit ihren tipps geben gut ok
meiner tecdax sind auch nicht viel
besser
[Musik]
ich hab nicht gedacht das kann nicht gut
klappen das kann aber das kann man
nichts wäre
[Musik]
ich lag heute nicht mehr ich habe
richtig krasse laufwerken slater
[Musik]
jetzt muss etwas trinken das ist schon
so ekelhaft wie das da rein schüttet
guckt euch diese scheiße an freundlich
weiß ich aber dass er kenne aber schon
so viel kakophonie so mache ich die
teile oder so randvoll und man auf die
lupe
ah ja
den kenne ich schon der achte jetzt mehr
auf dem kopf schneller läuft weiter den
kenn ich glaube ich auch schon die hat
er rutscht aus
da kommt man schon erahnen die cup
tätige drauf die rutsche runter also ein
paar videos kenne ich jetzt tatsächlich
schauen aber das video ist eigentlich
relativ neu also die computer ist noch
nicht das ist noch nicht das haben wir
auch irgendwas was ich das kenne ich
auch das sind alles nur sachen die wir
tun da lag ich ja nicht über ein 1 1
wie gesagt
tut einfach nur weh das ist doch nicht
sein der sitzt doch keiner von ihnen
denkt sich immer mal was sagt marco russ
meine coupé hier ja um eine brille oder
das ist obi ich bin es der schnellste
rapper von deutscher weiß nicht genau
was du nicht schreibt das ist die kraft
auf den lukas shop
ich wollte eigentlich ins klo kippen
aber ich habe dann doch noch
ausgestrahlt auf die leute das ist
ich habe es schon oft genug gezeigt in
diesem video aber schaut euch das an das
ist man denkt was ein bisschen so wie
wenn man durch fall trinken erkennt ihr
das wenn man den beiden donnerstagen
unterstellen wir immer dunkel sind
ungesund du machst einfach für ungesund
hier salat gebe ich ihm recht
oh nein das weiß ich nicht das meint sie
nicht
nein mein gott was habe ich gelacht aber
dass das war das erkennt also ich trinke
auf keinen fall nochmal
heute gab seien nicht auf radio und mein
gott du kannst doch dessen sehen und
herzlich auf die st
zunächst harmlos spielen ich wollte dich
mehr fragen möchtest du maine et net
sein freue mich auf antwort von dir
befüllt leute kennt ihr das wenn ihr
kein abo hat dann könnt ihr immer das
pflegen und so spielen mit freunden so
weit gehen
was'n live heute wenn ihr mal keinen
akku auf eurem handy haben sollte mega
gute taktik kauft euch einfach das pop
sorge die aus dem lukas ob da könnt ihr
dann einfach hier so dass die ganze zeit
so hoch und runter machen
mega hammer gibt zu kaufen und apropos
camino shop.de
da gibt es auch über diesen tollen die
das ist ein smiley und da vorne steht
drauf werde also dienst des oder wenn
ihr brennholz für den winter braucht es
auch gut geeignet
oh mein gott da kommt was relevanter
gelaufen wenn er im auto tritt liebe tod
mein gott das gibt auch ein video das
kann ich mir vielleicht finde ich das
mal kurz das jetzt auch so ein video wo
leute einfach mit ihrer karte direkt an
den löwen herfahren und dann kommt so
eine löwin hin und schildkröten
[Musik]
ich habe den vorstand getrunken und im
mund gelassen so gehört weil der so
ekelhaft geschmeckt hat und dabei hab
ich den runtergeschluckt alles meine
nase es ist für den ford mit etwas
studieren
bei uns ist das so hier sind paten wir
sind aber auch beste freunde gleich sind
wir aber auch geschwister
[Musik]
vielleicht wird aus spaß und schott ganz
gut tun ich habe einfach ist
schweinefleisch gegessen ist alles klar
[Musik]
das heute wieder ist alex aber ende
natürlich die freude wenn euch diesen
nicht lachen change gefallen hat und
wenn ich mich selbst darüber einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freundschaften wir 40.000 like das
wären mega krass und wird mir zeigen
euch gefallen diese nicht lachen
challenge ich kann gar nicht mehr
richtig reden weil mein hals voll mit
ingwer stückchen näher ist abonniert
allerdings auf jeden fall meinen kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der user das
ist kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr und wenn ihr schon abonnent klickt
auch gerne auf die glocke denn dann
bekommt eine benachrichtigung sobald ich
ein neues video täglich hochladen
die fresse du lachen
[Musik]